now world leaders are not doing enough
to prepare for more intense
environmental and security crises that's
according to a major peace studies
institute the stockholm international
peace research institute or cpr says the
world is entering a new era of risk
where environmental and security issues
overlap it says droughts heat waves and
other impacts of climate change are
increasingly driving conflicts around
the world according to the report while
temperatures rose worldwide between 2010
and 2020 the number of armed conflicts
doubled as did the number of refugees
and we're joined now by margaret
valstrom the former swedish foreign
minister and chair of the international
panel that guided the research
a very warm welcome to dw good to have
you with us now the report
uh suggests that there is a link between
worsening crises and security and the
environment could you perhaps give us
some concrete examples where these
problems reinforce each other
well it's easy to imagine that a country
that has a lack of drinking water and
shares
a water source a river with
neighboring countries
and because of climate change there is
less and less water to to share this
could easily lead to
social unrest and conflicts and in the
worst case war and we see that in in
many places around the world but also
how of course
some some of these problems lead to
people fleeing leaving their country so
we have so many more refugees and
climate change
refugees so i think that there are a
number of these elements showing the
link between peace and security and
growing environmental problems
now looking at the war in ukraine aside
from the human cost it's also
destabilized european security and
affected global food and energy supplies
what further consequences do you see on
the horizon
well it's very clear
that the the russia war in ukraine
has also and already led to
[Music]
i would say huge impact on the rest of
the world there is
less
wheat
for example so people
go without bread in many countries and
other exports of crops
that cannot be harvested now in both
ukraine and
uh also in in russia um
sends waves of problems around the world
and of course the whole oil and gas
export from from russia also being
impacted by by sanctions and so on so we
we depend on each other we understand
that some of these problems
follow a wind or a river and we just
have to take that into account we have
to live with some of these risks we have
to avoid them
now your report says that institutions
including governments are reacting too
slowly briefly if you would what actions
should they be taking now
well they have to cooperate first of all
they have to make sure that they
they look into the future and identify
some of these
these environmental problems that can
also have a spillover effect
and
they just have to think more long-term
and they have to take into account what
climate change will will do and they
have to improve their their planning and
also in engage be deliberately uh
inclusive as we say so talk to those
people that will be uh affected uh and
involve them in the planning for the
future
all right margaret valstrom former
swedish foreign minister thank you so
much for your time
thank you